ça fera qu'un simple quand un boxeur
monte dans le ring il le fait à ses
risques et périls
et pour être certain d'être à l'abri
d'éventuelles poursuites ou l'obligent à
signer une décharge dans beaucoup de
contrats on va on va trouver aussi une
clause
comme quoi que l'athlète ne peut avoir
aucun recours aux comptes contre x que
ce soit promoteurs aux régies qu'il est
clairement conscient qu'il s'engage dans
une compétition de haute niveau ce qui
est des risques de blessures de tous
genres monde efraim taxi ali nestor a
été boxeur professionnel pendant plus de
dix ans avant d'ouvrir son gymnase aux
jeunes en difficulté du quartier saint
michel
pour lui il n'ya pas de doute c'est
vraiment l'athlète qui prend la majorité
des risques
il ya d'autres personnes qui prennent
des risques financiers mais rien à voir
avec lorsqu'on parle de sa santé
en plus de signer une décharge de
responsabilité le boxeur doit contracter
lui même une assurance et bien souvent
les chiffres sont prohibitifs compte
tenu des dangers à boxer moyen peut
payer plus de 5000 dollars par an mais
la plupart monte dans le ring sans
assurance il n'y a pas énormément de
compagnies d'assurance qui sont prêtes à
couvrir quelqu'un qui est un sport de
contact quoi pour un sport de combat
donc moi je me rappelle avait réussi à
en trouver une
et cette compagnie ben me chargeais le
double de d'ailleurs quand deux
pugilistes monte dans le ring
ils sont consentants selon la loi
canadienne avec cette entente préalable
on exclut la boxe du code criminel mais
ce n'est pas le cas de tous les sports
hockey par exemple le code criminel
s'applique
l'avocat richard pascone et a défendu un
joueur de hockey senior qui avait
fracturé la mâchoire un ses adversaires
lors d'un match et qui avait été
poursuivi
mon client avait sorti du cadre du
pakistan dans ce cas là et à ce moment
là il ya une plainte au criminel et
aussi on doit rester dans les règlements
simplement
et lorsqu'on sort du règlement tant
qu'elles ont un risque quand même
d'avoir une plaine contre une
alors pourquoi la boxe et cheptel à ses
règlements à la boxe ont le droit de se
frapper
même si dans la vie ce serait un watt
faits graves
ça fait partie du sport day co
malheureusement le débat sur la
dangerosité de la boxe est loin d'être
terminée et même la classe politique
québécoise se demande comment mieux
protéger les athlètes
en attendant on peut se demander si le
boxeur est vraiment le grand gagnant
dans ce combat robert frosi radio canada
montréal